hey
oh wow hey guys how's it going
i don't feel like i was particularly
political or progressive growing up
you know we weren't raised in a super
political or an
ideological household yeah no not at all
because i remember when i was running
i told my mom i was like yeah my i think
i'm gonna it sounds like kind of crazy
but i think i'm gonna run for congress
and she was like oh what's that like a
community board
and i was like yeah it's a little bigger
than that
and then i won she was like oh this is
like
this is like a big deal like
she's looking at herself on television
right now
how are you feeling can you put it into
word nope
and i was like yeah i didn't think this
was going to happen
it is easily the most shocking result of
this political season thus far
veteran new york city democratic
congressman joe crowley has gone down to
primary defeat tonight at the hands
of a 28-year-old opponent named
alexandria ocasio-cortez the youngest
woman to ever
represent a district united states
congress you famously did not have any
experience in politics before this job
guys there are secret underground
tunnels between all of these government
buildings i was like this is
crazy
but this is possible
despite the fact that we didn't have the
money despite the fact
that i'm working class we won
how's it been going i'm pretty good
you're signing everyone up for the
century amazing
as you know we kind of come around we
try to help people with census
voter registration yeah i'm ready to
sign up for expenses
ms miller i work for gracie square
hospital
yeah i'm listen to worker oh thank you i
really appreciate you
you're the best you rock you know that
thank you take a picture of us
thank you two three years ago if i was
on the subway nobody
cared and that type of environment has
changed but being home that hasn't
changed
our family keeps everybody home that is
true you will always get roasted
you will always be made fun of you
people will always bring
up embarrassing family stories nice and
grounded
that's never been a concern nice and
grounded
[Music]
i still live in the same neighborhood
that i've always lived in
to be able to go into my bodega every
time i go home
that to me is really grounding a lot of
our cousins and families still live in
the same apartments and neighborhood
that
they always have growing up to impart
just dirty and southpaw
yeah between porchester and the south
bronx we call each other cousins
that is super latino i had diaz and
theos that i didn't know
that i wasn't actually blood related to
until i was
a really grown adult you visit your
theist and they have like the wood
beaded
curtain between doors and you go like
this and you're like what's up
plastic covers on the couches you know
it's not a landmark but
it's home home yeah it's home ethan
my name is alexandria thank you i
remember you too we were on we were in
the bronx the last time we met right
so i have my niece my nephew my
friend's good daughter my friend's son
and this is my
little nephew right here
[Applause]
i actually didn't think that i would be
suited for
politics yeah ever you know
it just seemed like a completely
different world
and then the 2016 election happened
all right here we go hey the election is
what prompted me to go to standing rock
we just got to camp
we're driving down a road flanked with
flags from all the different tribes that
are here
i'd never done anything like that before
i just had a very very profound
experience there
how i felt was i don't know what i'm
going to do
but i feel like i need to dedicate all
of myself
to trying to make the world a better
place you made the decision before you
knew what it was
and then literally as i was
driving off the camp i got an email
about the idea of running for congress
back home
i was still bartending at the time
i remember kind of looking down and
being like
what would it take i think i just felt
like i needed to run not necessarily to
win or to lose but i was being called to
do this thing at this time
you